Олія, консерви - 2 пачки,
чай, горошок...
Продуктовий набір із 16 позицій та побутова хімія. Вартість - приблизно 250 гривень.
Цього літнім людям має вистачити приблизно на два тижні,
доки вони через карантин не можуть виходити з дому.
Про такі пайки для людей похилого віку подбав благодійний фонд "Старенькі",
який і до карантину розсилав такі набори. Але нині, в часи коронавірусу,
фонду дуже бракує волонтерів. Марта з друзями
вирішила на карантині не байдикувати, а допомогти.
Зараз є особлива потреба у волонтерах,
тому що стареньким і так важко, а тут ще й карантин.
Також є такий момент, що волонтери, які раніше розвозили продукти,
тепер хтось боїться вірусу, а у когось виникає проблема з громадським транспортом.
А ми можемо собі це дозволити,
бо ми маємо свій транспорт і дотримуємося всіх санітарних норм.
Волонтерський рух із допомоги стареньким набирає обертів по цІлій країні.
Люди об’єднуються в соцмережах, збирають дані про потреби літніх людей.
Це не лише продукти, але й ліки.
У нас і раніше у Харкові не вистачало інсуліну, а нині ситуація просто в глухому куті.
Хворі не мають інсуліну й не можуть вийти з дому.
Але навіть якщо у них були б рецепти, в аптеках інсуліну все одно немає.
Для 67-річної харків’янки Лариси Клімової цей інсулін - на вагу золота.
Дякую тобі!
Я взагалі цього не очікувала. Дякую!
Ціле багатство!
Про потреби стареньких волонтери дізнаються
від соціальних служб, які обслуговують насамперед самотніх
чи тих, у кого діти теж пенсійного віку.
Волонтерка Марта Родіонова власною автівкою розвозить продуктові набори.
Разом із нею - соціальна працівниця.
Це масочка.
А її можна прати?
Прасується, все добре.
Завідувачка одного з відділень центру соціального захисту Шевченківського району
Анна Зелінська каже, що тепер працівники мають допомагати не лише тим,
хто в них був на обліку до карантину, а всім стареньким,
які опинилися у скрутному становищі.
У нас телефони стаціонарні не замовкають.
Телефонують усі, хто зареєстрований у нашому відділені.
У нас їх 953 людини.
А також дзвонять незареєстровані, бо вони не можуть вийти і просять,
щоб допомогти, допомогти, допомогти.
На жаль, у нас не вистачає змоги.
Руки потрібні, щоб розвозити.
46-річна Ірина Авдієнко працює в соцслужбі територіальногоцентру Подільського району.
У неї особисто 10 підопічних бабусь та дідусів, яких вона має відвідувати раз на тиждень:
але тепер дістатися до них - це додаткове випробування.
Подолом нині фактично курсує лише один трамвай, і той
не за маршрутом, де мешкають підопічні Ірини.
Жінка жартує, що побила всі рекорди з ходіння пішки:
щоденно намотує не менше 10 кілометрів, та ще й тягає
важкі пакети на верхні поверхи будинків без ліфту.
У нас за нормою - не більше 6 кг на руки.
Буває, що беру більше, щоб в одне місце двічі не ходити.
83-річна Алла Сергіївна дуже чекає на Ірину. Її чоловік давно помер, і вона мешкає одна.
Алочка Сергіївна, я Вам купила всі покупки.
Дякую, дай Вам Бог здоров'я!
Цілую та обіймаю Вас дистанційно.
Ірининої допомоги по господарству Аллі Сергіївні дуже бракує.
Доповзу до кухні, зварю гречану кашу.
А Іра принесе мені сиру, так я шматочок покладу в кашку та кефірчиком заллю.
Мені багато не треба. Головне, щоб було, що їсти.
Багатьом стареньким потрібна також психологічна підтримка в часи карантину,
коли вони змушені сидіти в чотирьох стінах.
Деякі психологина добровільних засадах надають їм таку підтримку телефоном.
Побачивши ситуацію, я запитала себе, як я можу допомогти.
У нас уже тисячі випадків, пов’язаних з вірусом.
Це лякає людей, провокує бурю емоцій, і це не обов'язково пов’язано зі страхом смерті.
Психологи в соціальних службах, каже Анна Зелінська, теж перевантажені.
Таких позитивно налаштованих пенсіонерів, як 68-річна Людмила Гаценко, дуже мало.
Сиджу вдома:
читаю, плету,
дивлюся телевізор, слухаю радіо.
Дуже багато корисних передач.
Роблю зарядку обов’язково. Готую цікаві страви.
Люблю готувати. Чекаю, поки ця "корона" нас покине
і дуже вам зичу, щоб ви були здорові. Щоб ви себе берегли.
Більшість соцпрацівників Києва - люди пенсійного віку.
Директорка територіального центру Подільського району зізнається,
що з жахом думає про те, що буде з підопічними центру,
якщо її співробітники захворіють.
Вони нині в зоні ризику і, відповідно до закону,
я мала би їх відправити додому. Але якщо їх відправити, то
60 відсотків людей залишиться без соцпрацівників.
Це проблема не тільки в нас, а загалом по Києву і по цілій Україні.
Служба така, яка...
Молодь до нас у чергу не стоїть, на жаль.
А працюють люди, в яких маленька пенсія
і з урахуванням нашої невеликої зарплати вони можуть якось прожити.
За розпорядженням президента, робітникам соцслужб під час карантину
мають підвищити зарплату на 100 відсотків.
У середньому соцпрацівники зазвичай отримують 6000 гривень.
Ірина у свої 46 - наймолодша у колективі Подільського територіального центру.
Вона часто проводить, як вона жартує, обряд дезінфекції,
і сподівається, що КМДА виконає обіцяне і надішле їм захисні та дезінфекційні засоби.
Соцпрацівникам потрібні не лише маски, але й костюми, як у медиків.
У нас є лежачі підопічні, яких треба перевернути, переодягнути, змінити памперси.
Крім нас, їх ніхто не перевіряє.
Але ж ми приходимо з вулиці і вже є носіями.
Ми приходимо до цієї людини, яка ослаблена.
Не буде в нас захисту - не факт, що ця людина завтра не захворіє і не помре.
Ірина завершує свій важкий робочий день.
Каже, служба не лише через карантин, а вже давно потребує волонтерської підтримки.
Держава могла б офіційно напрявляти соцпрацівникам на підмогу студентів
на час практики або молодих чоловіків, які проходять, приміром,
альтернативну службу в армії.
Якщо зляжуть соцпрацівники, не виключено, що їхні обов'язки
доведеться виконувати нацгвардійцям.
Інакше тисячі стареньких людей помруть не від коронавірусу,
а від елементарної нестачі ліків, продуктів або догляду.